the Joe Rogan experience right look
there's no one's gonna pass the purity
test
no one they're just looking for
something and I think that again it goes
back to the thing like that's not nice
like if all your your constant now it's
not the time to be nice Joe now is the
time for rage there was someone that
someone wrote something about oh that
guy from CNN what's his name brian
Stelter Stelter and that looks like
divine out of drag that's that guy he
wrote something about about the the like
angry journalism right woody bro but it
was like widely criticized why well
because it was like basically he's
admitting that this is not you're not
doing journalism this is like editorial
it's an actual direct very yeah yeah
it's like you're that guy for activism
more than you're calling for marketing
the news it's just what and just believe
that you're correct so you're gonna like
push your idea I mean this is what we
would go to the news what I really want
is someone who's gonna tell us exactly
what happened without any political bend
to it that's what the way I still even
saying that I still expect I'm probably
gonna see a little bit of it people
figure it and there's probably gonna be
that and when I was a kid it was like
that but not near to now where it's
become like a Miss a caddy gossip mixed
with news yeah now it's [ __ ] because
it's all - it's all because women shared
more online that's why they're targeting
the emotions of women that's
specifically this is a design this is
what the same thing we're talking about
with the Elan Mustang like how could you
he say that he didn't do that when he
can he can show you all these tweets
like how can you how can you accuse
someone just out to get him dude I mean
right like how is that where are we in
the news it's like if you some rapper
talking about how the cops won't leave
him alone like he's like a guy like the
cops are always gonna bother him you
know like that he just got on the bad
side of it's an institution and all
these institutions if you talk about
they hate you like though they have it
in for you it's great to see you think
of like a cop it's corrupt going but
the thin blue wine and bluntly but
you're a [ __ ] dirty like yeah but we
that's how they are with Elon Musk
something wrong with a bunch of people
that's so crazy it's not like so much
about justice let's say as it is about
processing in the system and [ __ ] that's
what their that's their job okay and
that's what they that's what they
[ __ ] did you find his quote a bunch
of people had made a meme out of it and
we're passing it around was him calling
no sir I forget the expression that he
used but I've read a real really wish I
could remember because I looked at
someone's a tweet about it or Instagram
about it and they were saying finally
you know you're admitting what what you
really do finally you're admitting that
your rage journalistic instincts are
show oh yeah rights rage journalism you
know it's been open for it they've been
open like that for a while I feel like
we need somewhere that's gonna give us
the information just clear 100 percent
dedicated to factual information without
any political Bend at all no one's well
the people somebody would be like it's
not possible so it might be my politics
it's got to be possible to be possible
yeah it's got to be possible to just
just read the news because if you if you
look at it every like there's gotta be
some other does that will start getting
views and you know what I mean like
somebody who fills that niche right it
will be successful because there's gonna
be people who should be able to report
on maybe dumb [ __ ] that Trump tweets and
also report at report on the the really
important things that are happening that
are good for they should just stop
reporting on Trump's tweets just try it
just [ __ ] try it for a minute you're
playing right into his hand first
it's like annihilation look what each
like he do and then while while they do
that he gets like a judge in or
something he does that all the time yeah
it's very savvy dude he always very
savvy in a lot of ways it's like the the
fake not sophisticated language that he
uses it's almost like he uses that to
kind of throw you off the trail I'm like
Don King with the crazy hair he's got
his own crazy hair it's almost like in
some ways it throws something about
crazy hair that really uh it throws you
off the trail but it's you know there's
no
there's no newspaper or no no thing that
I subscribe to or I don't get at least
some political bias one way or the other
you know what just clearly mark the
stuff that's editorial or like you know
this is not news just market is that if
the house I'm have news and they're not
the news you save one for the part that
it goes yeah everybody just do their job
you don't have to [ __ ] uh
to the Daily Show I blame a lot of this
on The Daily Show not because it was bad
a whole bunch of people that became news
for them right and so then all like all
the other ones like why don't we have it
like Daily Show but more news than
comedy so true people it's terrible it's
terrible it's such a good point that I
never even saw yeah I'm sure someone
said it but it's a it's a great point
it's right that's news for a lot of kids
like college kids they're barely paying
attention to flip it through Comedy
Central and Jon Stewart's in there
telling them what's going on in their
hilarious way in a hilarious Trevor Noah
want like that's a different generation
cuz I would just be like why is it I'm
by the way I know it I met him before
like I like him but I'm just a fan like
why you have some guy that shows not an
American white leg we're just with a guy
with a foreign accent here it's
beautiful all these all these shows that
are like the admit it's always some
enough from here that's interesting like
John Oliver same things I know I even
like him he's they seem to have a
[ __ ] would he call it like a I don't
have that kind of feeling of like I like
I always have a level of that like
before you write like I can't imagine
going England's doing a political show
about their politics
[Applause]